if your name is mentioned and people say
oh hell
oh damn i think you're doing something
wrong
courage is the most important important
of all the virtues
because without courage you can't
practice any other virtue there's an
african saying which is be careful when
a naked person
offers you a shirt i thought
that i had caused the man's death
because i had spoken his name she was an
american poet and civil rights activist
she's best known for her series of seven
autobiographies which focuses on her
childhood and early adult experiences
she was respected as a spokesperson for
black people and women and her works
were considered as a defense of black
culture she's maya angelou and here's my
take on her top 10 rules for success
rule number one was my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end for some special bonus
clips
also as she's talking if there's
something she says that really resonates
with you
please write it down in the comments and
put quotes around it so that other
people can be inspired as well
i have a painting by phoebe
of a group that she called sister suki's
funeral
and they all the women they're about
nine women and they
they all look like women in my
grandmother's uh prayer meeting group
so whenever i'm obliged to do
something i take that painting and i
look at that painting there's an empty
chair
and i think now what would grandma do
what would she
say i can almost hear her voice
say now sister you know what's right
just do right you don't really have to
ask anybody the truth is
right may not be expedient it may not be
profitable
but it will satisfy your soul
it brings you the kind of protection
that bodyguards can't give you
try to be all you can be to be the best
human being you can be
try to be that in your church in your
temple
try to be that in your classroom do it
because it is right to do
you see people would know you
and they will add their prayers to your
life they'll wish you well
i think if your name is mentioned and
people say oh hell
oh damn i think you're doing something
wrong
but if your name is mentioned and people
say oh she's so sweet
he's so nice oh i love oh god bless her
there you are so try to live your life
in a way that you will not regret
years of useless virtue and inertia
and timidity take up the uh
the battle take it up it's yours this is
your life
this is your world i'll be leaving it
long before you under the ordinary set
of circumstances
you make your own choices you can decide
life isn't worth living and that would
be the worst thing you can do how do you
know
so far try it
see so pick it up
pick up the battle and and make it a
better world
just where you are
yes and it can be better and it must be
better
but it is up to us i mentioned courage
and i would i would like to say
something else about that
finding courage in the leaders and in
you who will become
leaders uh courage is the most important
important of all the virtues
because without courage you can't
practice any other virtue
consistently you see you can't be
consistently
kind or fair or
humane or generous
not without courage because if you don't
have it sooner or later you'll
stop and say ah the threat is too much
the the difficulty is too too high the
the challenges is too great you know i
believe that self-love is very important
if you read my work you know i'm always
talking about
loving oneself i never trust anybody who
tells me he
or she loves me if the person doesn't
love herself
or himself there's an african saying
which is
be careful when a naked person offers
you a shirt
i mean if he had something to cover
himself first right
so i like to look at self-love
it is very important that it comes from
within
that you have a sense of yourself so
that when you walk into an
office you don't go alone
bring your people with you bring
everybody who has loved you with you
say grandma come on let's go great
grandpa you've been dead all this time
come on let's go
i have to go in here and have an
interview come on auntie
come on my friends come let's go and
when you walk in
people don't know what it is about you
they can't take their eyes off you
you may not be cute in the given sense
you may not be
fly fashion model size in that
particular sense
you may not be any of those things but
they can't take their eyes off you
and they say of you uh in a in this
incredible way which
i don't understand they say i don't know
but she has
charisma no what you have is all those
people around you
so think of that anytime you have
anything to do
bring everybody with you that you can
remember
who has loved you and then you have that
sense of having been paid for and when
you walk in people will say now
i think you're overqualified if you
don't laugh you will die
you know you really must laugh and if
every human being in the world would
admit it
he or she is the funniest person you've
ever met and
the truth is i mean some people just
rather be a little stodgy and
boring and you know but the truth is
they themselves
know that they're very funny um
the sense of humor is in in self-defense
against those who have pretend not to
have any sense of humor
and against the the cruelties of life
one
must laugh there's an african-american
song 19th century
which is so great
it says when it looked like the sun
wasn't going to shine anymore
god put a rainbow
in the clouds imagine and i've had so
many rainbows in my clouds
i had a lot of clouds
but i have had so many rainbows and one
of the things i do
when i step up on a stage when i stand
up
to translate when i go to teach my
classes
when i go to direct a movie i bring
everyone who has ever been kind to me
with me
black white asian spanish-speaking
native american
gay straight everybody i say come with
me
i'm going on the stage come with me i
need you now
long dead you see
so i don't ever feel i have no help
i've had rainbows in my clouds
and the thing to do it seems to me
is to prepare yourself so that you can
be a rainbow in somebody else's cloud
somebody who may not look like you may
not call
god the same name you call god if they
call god at all
you see i may not eat the same dishes
prepared the way you do
may not dance your dances or speak your
language
but be a blessing to somebody
when i was seven and a half i was raped
um
i won't say severely raped all rape is
severe
the rapist
was a person very well known to my
family
i was hospitalized
the rapist was let out of jail
and was found dead that night
and the police suggested that the rapist
had been kicked
to death i was seven and a half
i thought that i had caused
the man's death because i had spoken his
name
that was my seven and a half year old
logic
so i stopped talking for five
years
now to show you again how out of evil
there can come good in those five years
i read every book in the black school
library i read all the books i could get
from the white school library
i memorized james well and johnson paul
lawrence done by county cullen and
langston hughes
i memorized shakespeare whole
plays 50
sonnets i memorized edgar allan poe
all the poetry never having heard it
i memorized it i had
long fellow i had guido mopass on
i had balzac
rudyard kipling i mean it was a catholic
kind of reading
and catholic kind of story
when i decided to speak
i had a lot to say and many ways in
which to say
what i had to say i listened to the
black
minister i listened to the melody of the
preachers
and i could tell when they would start
up on that
kind of thing when they know they mean
to take our soul straight to heaven
or whether they meant to dash us
straight to hell
i understood it so out of this
evil which was a dire kind of evil
because rape on the body of a young
person
more often than not introduces
cynicism and there is nothing quite
so tragic as a young cynic
because it means the person has gone
from knowing nothing
to believing nothing in my case i was
saved
in that muteness you see
in the surada i was saved
and i was able to draw from human
thought
human disappointments and triumphs
enough to triumph myself we don't
understand talent
we don't understand electricity we
probably use
one billion of one billionth
percentage a less i mean
and a degree so infinitesimal that we
couldn't even say how little it is
you can plug into two holes in the wall
you can uh light up a cathedral you can
light up a
synagogue you can light up a temple
right
you can light up a surgery or you can
electrocute a person
strapped in a chair electricity makes no
demands
it says i'm here that's right if you are
stupid you will ill-use me
if you're intelligent you will use me
for the furtherance
of your kind
well i think talent is like that we
don't know what it is
but a painter maybe he or she is born
with the eyesight
to see depth and you understand to have
sure but that's physical um
maybe she is born with the throat that
makes her sound like a bird you know
a claratura lyric soprano baritone
but singing has very little to do with
voice
it is okay but if it really was about
voice ray charles and willie nelson
wouldn't be mentioned
that's true you know i just did a story
on autism
and it was uh the people who couldn't
write couldn't express themselves but
saying
in pitch and pitch and beautifully and
can
and can compute 40
columns of three numbers
each right how do they do that
that's talent that's talent i don't know
it i mean i thank god i have it
but i think every person born is born
with talent there's a place in you
that you must keep in violate
you must keep it pristine
clean so that nobody has the right to
curse you up
treat you badly nobody no mother father
no wife no husband knows
nobody because that may be the place you
go to when you meet
god you have to have a place with did
you say stop it
back up not you must not
no no absolutely and that's one i told
you
25 years ago yes say no when it's no
yeah say so back it up because that
place
has to remain clean and clear
and that has to be a place within you
yes ma'am yeah when you're writing
poetry
are you writing to express your
experiences
or do you write to inspire other people
no i write to
to try to say what i see what i've seen
and of course i hope that it's
inspirational
when you were writing phenomenal woman
did you realize how many millions of
women would be inspired by that no
i don't realize any of that i just i
just do the best i can
you may write me down in history with
your bitter twisted lies
you may trod me in the very dirt but
still like
dust alright
does my sassiness upset you why are you
beset with gloom
just because i walk as if i have oil
wells pumping in my
living room just like
moons and like suns with the certainty
of tides just like hope springing high
still i rise did you want to see me
broken
bowed head and lowered eyes shoulders
falling down like tear drops
weakened by my soulful cries does my
sassiness upset you
don't take it so hard just because i
laugh
as if i have gold mines digging in my
own backyard you can shoot me with your
words
you can cut me with your lies you can
kill me with your hatefulness but just
like
life all right
does my sexiness offend you oh
does it come as a surprise that i dance
as if i have diamonds at the meeting of
my thighs
out of the huts of history shame i rise
up from a past rooted in pain i rise
a black ocean leaping and wide
welling and swelling and bearing in the
tide
leaving behind nights of terror and fear
i rise into a daybreak miraculously
clear
i rise bringing the gifts that my
ancestors gave
i am the hope and the dream of the slave
and so
wow there i go
thank you guys so much for watching i
made this video because kayla maroon
asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and i'll see what i can
do i'd also love to know what you
thought of the video what clips
resonated the most with you what
what did you learn that's going to
change your business or your life
leave it in the comments and i will join
in the discussion finally i want to give
a quick shout out to philip norton
phillip thank you so much for buying a
copy of my book
really means a lot to me those you guys
watching if you want your chance at a
shout out in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipts so we can keep track
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and i'll see you soon
if we've been able to stay alive
at all alive and
future thinking alive and having enough
courage to care for each other
enough courage to love and know that we
are probably one percent
free i mean let's what one percent
of 60 million free of uh
of complaints imagine
who would we be
who would we be if we were
percent of 600 million six billion
what would happen i tell you one thing
i think war would be laughed out of the
room
i think the very word somebody said
warren
another person would say you mean am i
supposed to kill somebody because he
doesn't agree with me
i don't think so just imagine
people would speak kinder more kindly
to each other courtesy would be in
invited back into the
living room into the bedroom into the
children's room
into the kitchen if one percent
of our world
was complaint free
we would care more about the children
and realize that every child is our
child
the black one and the white one the
pretty one the plain one
the asian and the muslim the japanese
and the jewish
everyone is our child
if we were just one percent
free of complaint imagine that we would
stop
blaming other people for our mistakes
and hating them because they caused the
mistake
in our minds just imagine if we laughed
more frequently
if we had the unmitigated
courage to touch each other
it would be a just beginning of paradise
you now thank you